[Musique]
certains appellerons ça un salaire
d'autres une grosse michtenade d'après
le magazine Public le footballeur
Cristiano Ronaldo verserait 100000 euros
par mois sa petite amie de 28 ans
Georgina je m'appelle Georgina Rodriguez
je rêvais d'avoir un prince charmant à
mes côtés et aujourd'hui je l'ai une
coquette somme qui sera officiellement
destinée aux dépenses et aux soins des
enfants je sais ce que c'est de ne rien
avoir
il se met aussi de tout avoir le
footballeur le mieux payé du monde avec
près de 115 millions d'euros par an la
somme est dérisoire mais quand même
Georgina et la femme de ma vie je suis
fou amoureux d'elle dans quelques
semaines Georgina couchera de jumeaux
l'occasion pour elle de renégocier son
argent de poche
[Musique]
alors
étant spécialiste en divorce quel
intérêt de verser quand on est encore
marié déjà une prestation
quand même bizarre mais il prend soin
d'elle c'est de l'argent
de ce qu'il y a une par mois donc déjà
ils sont fous complètement c'est rien
pour lui c'est normal qu'ils prennent
soin d'elle genre génial fait rêver
plein de gens il y a sa série sur
Netflix qui est sorti
et elle raconte qu'elle était vendue
chez Gucci au départ de sa carrière
c'est comme ça qu'elle l'a rencontré et
depuis les candidatures chez Gucci ont
explosé donc c'est une histoire qui fait
rêver il a raison bien s'occuper d'elle
ah bah oui oui j'ai là
2 secondes là il va les défoncer j'ai
une vision un tout petit peu moins
romantique c'est comme pour les stars
américaines à ce niveau là disons que je
veux pas dire que la relation est
contractualisée mais il y a un accord
financier dès le départ de la relation
c'est-à-dire quoi qu'ils sont plus
ensemble non non ils sont ensemble mais
chaque mois on donne de l'argent tout ça
a été écrit etc ça fait partie du deal
entre guillemets amoureux ce qui me
semble qu'on Amérique maintenant il y a
eu tellement de désastre dans les
divorces que là-bas quand vous divorcer
alors en France parfois c'est un peu dur
hein mais alors là-bas je peux vous dire
que là-bas c'est on vous met en slip on
vous prend tout et iPack maintenant dans
les contrats de mariage il y a déjà
toutes les clauses pour le divorce et
dans ce cas-là par exemple dans le cas
de tromperie par exemple je crois que
c'était Michael Douglas quand il quand
il était avec Catherine Zeta-Jones le
nombre il y avait une clause si jamais
elle trompait elle était trompée elle
prenait déjà 100 millions d'euros la 22
dollars français
c'est incroyable
aux États-Unis ça dépend des états
chaque état a des lois différentes et
justement le le divorce de Tom Cruise et
Nicole Kidman avait été extrêmement
médiatisé les gens s'étaient posé la
question de savoir s'il divorçait le
timing du divorce parce que justement
après 10 ans il aurait dû lui payer des
sommes alors je sais plus s'ils ont
divorcé juste avant ou juste après mais
ça avait fait une polémique à cause de
ça parce que vous avez raison le nombre
d'années tout est négocié à l'avance et
le niveau de jolies et de Brad Pitt
c'est toujours pas réglé il y a le il y
a le château en France
c'est même pas beaucoup 100000 euros
vues
et en plus c'est la maman de ses enfants
elle va avoir des jumeaux elle a 28 ans
elle a 37 millions d'abonnés c'est pas
n'importe qui cette fille c'est bien la
raison moi je lui donnerai deux trois
cent mille euros
c'est c'est marrant comme c'est marrant
comme on est généreux avec l'argent des
autres c'est un psychologue
si je gagne un milliard au loto je le
donne bah oui bah c'est pas c'est pas
mal quand même je peux le dire je m'en
fous je les ai pas bien sûr oh vous êtes
bien quand même vous et 115 millions non
mais oui j'ai l'impression que ça choque
que moi sans déconner c'est ça femme et
lui donne 5000
€. ils sont actuellement mariés s'ils
étaient divorcés je comprends il y
aurait une pension à la protège aussi
c'est de la prostitution
je comprends que ça le choc
pourquoi payer sa femme pour lui faire
plaisir
de Ronaldo celle-là doit marcher mais
alors
qu'on entretien de son enfant d'accord
mais qu'on entretient sa femme c'est
normal
ses enfants donc forcément Cristiano
Ronaldo n'est pas à côté d'elle toute la
journée donc il faut bien que puisse
utiliser elle-même ses sous tu vois ce
que veut dire perso mais je trouve ça
glauque mon perso
c'est pas le mécanisme quoi j'imagine
que je vais lâcher un pavé dans la barre
mais est-ce que ça ne cache pas autre
chose mais oui les enfants ils ont été
fait avec des pipettes ouh là là là
voilà donc
c'est quand même ce qui serait pas enfin
voilà
c'est une rumeur
de rémunérer le fait d'être un paravent
j'ai parlé de contrat vous allez un peu
plus loin quoi je la forêt il y a un
plan fictif derrière
voilà les amis encore à moi à dire sur
ça non mais c'est pas parce que vous
vous aimez les hommes gourmands que tout
le monde les aime
[Applaudissements]
je rigole mais en vrai ça n'a rien à
voir c'est normal de prendre soin de ça